AMBASSADOR GORDON SONDLAND
FROM TESTIFYING.
WE BEGIN WITH CHIEF WHITE
HOUSE CORRESPONDENT JOHN
ROBERTS WITH BREAKING NEWS
ON A NUMBER OF FRONTS
TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> BRET, GOOD EVENING TO YOU
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
PUSHBACK COMING FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY TO THE
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY ON THE
HILL IN THAT LETTER TO NANCY
PELOSI.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN JUST
A MOMENT.
BUT, FIRST, IT APPEARS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP MAY SOON
HAVE MORE INFORMATION TO
BOLSTER HIS CLAIMS THAT HIS
CAMPAIGN AND HIS PRESIDENCY
HAVE BEEN UNFAIRLY TARGETED
FOR INVESTIGATION.
>> A SENIOR ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIAL TELLS FOX NEWS
EXCLUSIVELY, THAT THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
GENESIS OF THE RUSSIA PROBE
IS EXPECTED TO BE RELEASED
LATER THIS MONTH AND THAT
ITS FINDINGS WILL BE
DETAILED.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INSPECTOR GENERAL MICHAEL
HOROWITZ HAS BEEN LOOKING
INTO WHETHER THERE WERE
ABUSES OF THE FISA SYSTEM TO
BEGIN SURVEILLANCE OF TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OFFICIALS THAT
ULTIMATELY LED TO THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
SOURCES ALSO SAY ANOTHER
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
RUSSIA PROBE.
THIS ONE HEADED UP BY
VETERAN PROSECUTOR JOHN
DURHAM HAS BEEN EXPANDED
BASED ON WHAT DURHAM IS
FINDING.
HE HAS ADDED STAFF AND
AGENTS AND HAS WIDENED THE
TIMELINE OF THE
INVESTIGATION PAST ELECTION
DAY AND INTO THE SPRING OF
2017 WHEN ROBERT MUELLER WAS
APPOINTED SPECIAL COUNSEL.
NO WORD ON WHEN DURHAM'S
INVESTIGATION WILL BE
COMPLETED.
FOX NEWS HAS ALSO LEARNED
THAT MUELLER WAS NOT
ACCURATE WHEN HE TOLD
CONGRESS ON JULY 24TH THAT
HE WAS NOT INTERVIEWING FOR
THE POSITION OF FBI DIRECTOR
WHEN HE MET PRESIDENT TRUMP
IN THE OVAL OFFICE IN MAY OF
2017.
>> MY UNDERSTANDING I WAS
NOT APPLYING FOR THE JOB.
I WAS ASKED TO GIVE MY INPUT
ON WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO DO
THE JOB.
>> MULTIPLE ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS TELL FOX NEWS THAT
WHEN MUELLER MET THE
PRESIDENT ON MAY 16TH, 2017,
HE WAS INDEED PURSUING THE
POST LEFT OPEN BY THE FIRING
OF JAMES COMEY A WEEK
EARLIER.
IN FACT, MUELLER WAS LOOKING
AT TWO POSSIBLE JOBS.
FBI DIRECTOR AND SPECIAL
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
ACCORDING TO DOCUMENTS
OBTAINED BY JUDICIAL WATCH
IN A FREEDOM OF INFORMATION
REQUEST, DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN HAD
TALKED WITH MUELLER ABOUT
THE POSSIBILITY OF BECOMING
SPECIAL COUNSEL BEFORE HE
MET WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IN AN EMAIL DATED MAY 12TH,
ROSENSTEIN WROTE TO MUELLER,
QUOTE, THE BOSS AND HIS
STAFF DO NOT KNOW ABOUT OUR
DISCUSSIONS.
THE DAY AFTER MUELLER MET
WITH THE PRESIDENT,
ROSENSTEIN APPOINTED HIM AS
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THE PRESIDENT'S FORMER
OUTSIDE ATTORNEY WAS
OUTRAGED THAT MUELLER
INTERVIEWED FOR THE FBI
POSITION KNOWING THAT HE
COULD BECOME SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
JOHN DOWD TELLING FOX NEWS
MUELLER'S ACTIONS WERE,
QUOTE:  THE MOST
DISHONORABLE CONDUCT I HAVE
EVER WITNESSED.
ON THE IMPEACHMENT FRONT,
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL PAT LATE
TODAY SENT A LETTER TO HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI AND THE
CHAIRS OF THREE HOUSE
COMMITTEES SLAMMING THE
IMPEACHMENT INVESTIGATION
SAYING PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
HIS ADMINISTRATION CANNOT
PARTICIPATE IN YOUR PARTISAN
AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL
INQUIRY.
IN THE LETTER CIPOLLONE
CITES THE VOTE IN THE FULL
HOUSE IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY
WRITING THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES HAS NEVER
ATTEMPTED TO LAUNCH AN
IMPEACHMENT NIRK AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT WITHOUT A MAJORITY
OF THE HOUSE TAKING
POLITICAL ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THAT DECISION.
CIPOLLONE BLASTS DEMOCRATS
FOR DENYING PRESIDENT TRUMP
THE DUE PROCESS OF FULLY
AUTHORIZED INQUIRE WOULD
ALLOW HIM SAYING HAVE YOU
DENIED PRESIDENT THE RIGHT
TO CROSS-EXAMINE WITNESSES,
TO CALL WITNESSES, TO
RECEIVE TRANSCRIPTS OF
TESTIMONY.
TO HAVE ACCESS TO EVIDENCE.
TO HAVE COUNSEL PRESENT AND
MANY OTHER BASIC RIGHTS
GUARANTEED TO ALL AMERICANS.
SO, BRET, WHAT THE WHITE
HOUSE COUNSEL IS BASICALLY
DOING HERE IS DARING NANCY
PELOSI TO HOLD A HOUSE IN
THE FULL HOUSE AND ALSO
DARING HER TO ESCALATE LEGAL
ACTION AGAINST THE LACK OF
COOPERATION FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE BECAUSE THE WHITE
HOUSE COUNSEL, PAT
CIPPOLLONE BELIEVES
PRECEDENT IS IMPORTANT HERE.
OTHER THREE TIMES PRESIDENT
HAS FACED IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS JOHNSON, NIXON
AND CLINTON THOSE, ALL THREE
OF THOSE WERE PRECEDED BY